en Israël le Premier ministre israélien
naphtali Bennett a affirmé ce dimanche
que ses efforts de médiation dans la
guerre était un devoir moral même s'il y
avait peu de chance de réussite outre
tentative de médiation le président turc
Redjep tahitoan qui s'est entretenu au
téléphone avec son homologue russe
Vladimir Poutine il réclame un cessez le
feu général
urgent en Ukraine suite à cette
entretien
erdon il peut jouer un rôle de médiateur
on sait qu'il est membre de l'OTAN mais
c'est aussi un allié conflictuel
il est concerné par par les trois en
fait parce que il est membre de l'OTAN
il a des accords c'est un allié de
l'Ukraine effectivement
et il entretient des relations certes
compliquées mais sur certains dossiers
comme le dossier syrien quand même assez
approche avec Moscou et en plus son
économie est très dépendante des
importations qui viennent de Russie donc
pour ces trois facteurs si vous voulez
il se dit qu'il est en position de
proposer lui aussi un peu comme il vient
de le faire le ministre israéliens une
médiation peut-être encore plus que le
premier ministre israélien parce que lui
en plus géographiquement il est vraiment
tout prêt des zones concernées la mer
Noire ensuite l'Ukraine il est vraiment
géographiquement impliqué en quelque
sorte donc il propose une médiation lui
aussi demande à cesser le feu en urgence
et puis il peut être entendu il peut
être entendu ça franchement je ne sais
pas ils essayent déjà les Turcs de faire
en sorte que le ministre des Affaires
étrangères Ukrainiens rencontre son
homologue russe la semaine prochaine
parce qu'il y a un forum diplomatique
qui se tient à antalyast en Turquie là
déjà ils espèrent que les deux
dirigeants des deux diplomaties pourront
se parler après ce qu'il croit vraiment
que c'est le feu général et urgent
est une possibilité réelle et qu'il peut
influer là-dessus je n'en suis pas sûr
mais il cherche quand même à jouer un
rôle pour montrer qu'il est un grand
acteur et jeune parce que chez Ardon il
y a quand même toujours ça il ne faut
pas l'oublier
peut être aussi une grande puissance
régionale et pour tous les facteurs que
j'ai que j'ai énumérés en début
d'intervention de ce point de vue là il
estime et ça peut se comprendre qu'il a
peut-être une carte à jouer donc il
essaye de la jouer et pour être complet
sur ces rôles des médiateurs on vient
d'apprendre que donc le chef de l'État
français Emmanuel Macron s'est entretenu
avec Vladimir Poutine et que c'est la
fin de l'appel téléphonique qui a duré
environ deux heures entre les deux chefs
d'État